is liking an ice cream just die culture
talking hey everyone I'm Abby sharp
welcome to Abby's kitchen
[Music]
in today's video we'll be taking a look
at vegan YouTuber Alexandra Anderson
before we get into the video let's do
another round of Abby's daily hunger
crushing combo I don't think we ever
need an excuse for needing a snack some
days we're just extra hungry so just had
breakfast like two hours ago but I'm
just feeling like I need a little
something something so let me show you
what I'm gonna make okay so I've got
some granola with hemp hearts and chia
seeds for some carbs and fiber and some
healthy fats gonna add a little kefir
which I love a little extra Protein Plus
probiotics we love to see it topping off
with some berries for some extra fiber
hmm and the perfect pairing built bars
white chocolate berry granola bar I am
obsessed with the white chocolate
coating these bars are so delicious I
love the kind of chewy crunchy texture
of the granola varieties and they're
made with real chocolate so they taste
like chocolate so just chopped it up for
a little extra texture and of course
protein this bar has 15 grams of protein
so tasty and so satiating
all the textures
so if you want to try build by yourself
check out the link in my description and
use my promo code abbysharp15 for 15 off
of your order and you can pause the
screen or look at the description to
check out my disclaimer including a
trigger warning to those with current or
previous experiences with disordered
eating so as always feel free to skip
this video if it's not supportive to
your journey and if you are not already
subscribed hit that subscribe button and
follow me over on Tick Tock and
Instagram at Abby's kitchen so Alexandra
is a Swedish vegan YouTuber living in
Spain who shares vegan recipes and how
to's for folks interested in eating a
plant-based diet a lot of you have sent
her channel to me because she's a
self-proclaimed intuitive eater so I am
very excited to take a little look-see
at some yummy vegan eats and hopefully
be inspired um so I'm gonna make
pancakes
foreign
[Music]
if you haven't tried it yet just do it
[Music]
oh that drizzle a tahini plus the date
syrup on the pancake stack is literal
genius and such a delicious way to add
an extra dose of healthy fats to your
pancakes I definitely need to try that
combo ASAP as for the breakfast itself I
love that the pancake recipe is like
super low fuss it only requires three
Pantry staple ingredients however I
would love to see a little bit more
protein in this breakfast to really
boost up the satiety Factor as we're
only getting around 12 grams of protein
just from the flour milk and Tahini so
maybe we could throw in some extra nut
butter or hem parts or some vegan
protein powder to the pancake mix as for
the date syrup I love it I think it
tastes amazing and it's very popular in
the Wellness Community as it does offer
a few additional benefits compared to
other liquid sweeteners like honey or
maple syrup so it has three times more
potassium and it even contains two grams
of fiber per tablespoon however I
wouldn't be relying on any kind of sugar
for your fiber intake so it's unlikely
to make any kind of major difference in
your diet when consumed in normal
healthy amounts of tahini two
tablespoons rice vinegar one tablespoon
tomato sauce one tablespoon maple syrup
one teaspoon Sriracha then just give it
a stir until it's thick like this with
some lettuce the brown rice cucumber red
cabbage pineapple the tofu cubes some
toasted sesame seeds and the delicious
dressing looks like a rainbow and it's
so satisfying this bowl looks incredibly
dreamy and I love that even though she
didn't have the exact ingredients she
was still able to whip this up with
whatever she had on hand and it still
came out looking fire so we're getting
lots of healthy fats here from the
tahini dressing and sesame seeds protein
from the tofu as well as tons of fiber
and micronutrients from the colorful
veggies pineapple and brown rice I also
love that Alexander uses words like
satisfying colorful and refreshing to
describe her food and was able to really
tune into what her body needed she
didn't need to label it as clean or make
any sensationalized claims about its
Health properties curing X Y and Z in
fact with the tamari she actually
mentioned that she doesn't use it
because it's gluten-free or trendy but
rather because she prefers The Taste
over soy sauce this is a great example
of what it means to consider the
intention behind our food choices and
really does separate an intuitive eater
from a Dieter so to really get in touch
with the intention behind your food
choices and strengthen your intuitive
eating skills you can ask yourself
questions like am I choosing to eat this
salad because it sounds good and
satisfying to me right now or am I
choosing it because it's low calorie and
because I ate pizza last night so I
should am I craving nice cream because
it's refreshing flavorful and a fun way
to eat fresh fruit or am I actually just
trying to hold off on my persistent
craving for like some Ben and Jerry's
ultimately the intention behind your
food choices should be free from any
internal or external criticism or
judgment and ideally be led by what
feels most physically and emotionally
satisfying to you do I count calories no
I don't count calories I did before
actually when I was younger but it only
brings more negative things than
positive things so I completely stopped
and now I just eat intuitively eat until
I'm full just enjoy my big bowls of
colorful foods every day without
worrying and that's so nice so we don't
necessarily think that counting calories
is objectively good or bad but again it
really comes down to intention and
whether or not it really serves you
physically and psychologically at the
end of the day so for example some folks
might find that counting calories really
helps them to eat enough food and also
get a better understanding of
macronutrients without any major
implications on their mental well-being
or relationship with food they can see
it as like objective data void of any
moral power and just move on with their
day but for the rest of us it can rob us
of so much of the joy in food it may
become an obsession consuming a huge
amount of mental real estate and
infringing on our social and personal
relationships so I'm glad that Alexander
had the self-awareness to realize that
counting calories just wasn't serving
her and instead chose to focus on
internal satiety cues to navigate her
eating while also prioritizing
satisfaction
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I love how Alexander's intention behind
having nice cream for a snack was simply
because she was hot from being outside
in the sun and needed something cool and
refreshing to eat not because an ice
cream is like a low calorie alternative
to a dessert that's full of baddies like
sugar and fat I'm also living for how
colorful and accessible her meals are
this recipe was made with just three
simple ingredients that are easily just
like sitting in your fridge right now
this snack is also balanced with protein
fiber and a bit of healthy fats from the
hemp seeds on top which all together
makes it a delicious hunger crushing
plant-based snack for a hot summer day
[Music]
thank you
I am Loki super jealous of this girl's
life I mean a burrito and banana bread
on the beach where do I sign up and even
though burritos often get like a bad
reputation because they are fast food
they're actually inherently pretty well
balanced I think when we try to think
about the nourishment inherent in a lot
of these kinds of so-called junk Foods
we can feel a lot more relaxed about
them don't forget that calories are
energy they're fuel so let's think about
how we can nourish and energize our body
with them and I also appreciate that
even though Alexandra has made a name
for herself as like a food vlogger she
gives herself a break and will eat out
sometimes as well I think seeing a lot
of these what in a day videos where
creators are making three elaborate
meals and three snacks a day from
scratch every single day can feel really
discouraging and overwhelming I know
that often makes me feel insecure
because I know in my life I would
literally just be cleaning up from one
meal only to start working on another
and who the [ __ ] has time for that
time for that so it is nice to see a
more relatability with content like this
so when I looked at this day and also a
few others from Alexandra I think it was
pretty clear that she has a good sense
of her body's needs without tracking or
measuring a thing and I review a lot of
vegan diets here and I'm often seeing
these extreme portrayals of a
plant-based life massive salads insane
smoothies mono meals with like a case of
fruit I don't think it really serves
anyone who are plant-based curious
because if they were to attempt that
they would probably feel like and they
also would likely have a hard time
meeting their caloric needs due to the
high volume and fiber and while
Alexandra is definitely getting a solid
variety of fruit and veggies in her day
she also made sure to balance her meals
with protein fat and carbs as well as
enough calories and we see this pretty
consistently throughout her channel for
example in her what I eat in a week
video she showcased a variety of rest
piece including grain bowls sheet pan
meals smoothies nice cream and stuffed
potatoes and not only are these recipes
balanced but they often use a lot of
pantry Staples and very few ingredients
making them super accessible and low
Fest even for folks with very basic food
skills so if you're looking to integrate
more plant-based recipes in your life
from like a non-restrictive intuitive
eating lens I think Alexandra is
definitely a girl and I'm very excited
to continue watching for more
plant-based inspo and on that note
that's all that I have for you guys
today if you like this video be sure to
give it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below on who or what you'd like to see
me review next subscribe to the channel
and I'll see you next time on Abby's
kitchen bye foreign
[Music]